on November 8th the U.S will hold 475
separate Federal elections if you vote
in the U.S you can vote in at least one
of them the results will determine who
controls these the two houses of
Congress after the 2020 election
Democrats controlled the House of
Representatives and the Senate as well
as the presidency the three bodies that
have to align if you want to make new
laws and they did but even when
government is split between the parties
each one of these bodies still holds
tremendous power on its own so the
importance of what this picture looks
like can't be overstated and each one of
these three outcomes contains a very
different story about the next two years
in the U.S
scenario one Democrats keep both houses
this is not considered the most likely
outcome the Democrats have gotten a ton
passed in the last two years my name's
Lee Zhou I am a politics reporter at Vox
I've been covering the hill for like
over six years now so if Democrats get
to stick with this arrangement
then what one
that they'll do is codify Roe v Wade
into federal law and that would mean a
national protection for access to
abortion Paid Family Leave subsidies for
child care Universal Pre-K the pro act
which protects people's ability to
organize and unionize but there's a
catch to all this and it's connected to
the reason Democrats haven't done any of
it yet these laws are subject to a rule
the Senate has it's called the
filibuster that requires not 51 out of
100 votes to pass a law but 60 out of
100 and Democrats want to change that
role
just not all Democrats they have
to be very narrow majority but they only
have 48 who are actually down to change
the rules and so they need at least 52
is kind of the magic number that
Democrats have been hoping for in order
to both change the rules and then pass a
lot of the bills that we've talked about
[Music]
scenario two Republicans win the House
of Representatives when the house is
controlled by a different party than the
presidency or the Senate that gives them
a lot of Leverage my name is still
Matthews I'm a reporter at Fox they also
have a lot of control over
investigations they can run committees
they can subpoena people they can make
people testify they can judge up
documents we can see that by going back
to the last time the government looked
like this one thing that the GOP
majority in in 2011 and onward did was
investigate the Obama Administration
extensively those are fast and furious
uh gun smuggling Scandal on the Benghazi
scandal after after those attacks
happened in 2012. easily obtained well
but within hours if not days after
Democrats won in 2018 they also launched
a bunch of Investigations into the Trump
Administration and and one of which
culminated in the first impeachment
investigations can matter a lot more
often than not they're kind of a
sideshow
my sense ahead of time is that that
lever of power will be less important
than the ability to block must pass
legislation on spending in the debt
ceiling
the debt ceiling fight in 2011 was was
one of the first stories I covered at
the Washington Post the ditzy Lane is
this limit on how much the federal
government can borrow almost the
entirety of the International Financial
system is built on the idea that U.S
treasury bonds are a safe asset once you
hit the debt ceiling they are no longer
a low risk asset that would lead to
investment and borrowing and homes and
everything being way more expensive
throughout the world which would be a
pretty major financial crisis
you need the House and Senate and the
president to agree for the debt ceiling
to be raised the the most dramatic
example of that happened in the summer
of 2011 the debt ceiling was coming due
in early August and that gave house
Speaker John Boehner and members of his
caucus incredible leverage unless the
Obama Administration was willing to let
the death ceiling be breached they kind
of had to come to a deal
ultimately 2.1 trillion dollars and cuts
the national parks Head Start programs
the FBI National Institutes of Health
the National Science Foundation One area
of the budget is pandemic prevention the
choice that was made to invest a lot
less in preventing pandemics as a part
of this deal it certainly couldn't have
helped I mostly expect this Congress to
be more Hardline in terms of their
demands and unwillingness to compromise
scenario three Republicans win the house
and the Senate
the Senate has to confirm any federal
judge I'm Ian milheiser I'm a lawyer and
I cover the Supreme Court for Vox
the president nominates anyone who's
going to be appointed to the federal
bench but they don't get the job unless
a majority of the Senate votes to
confirm that individual there's a little
more than 800 active judges in the
federal system there are district judges
who try cases court of appeals or
circuit judges and then there's the
Supreme Court the last time we had a
Democratic president and a Republican
Senate was in 2015 and 2016. under
Barack Obama the Republican Senate
basically hit stop on Supreme Court
confirmations and on nearly all court of
appeals confirmations and then of course
what happened was Republicans held all
their seats open until Donald Trump got
into office and then filled them with
Republicans
Trump's judges have overruled Roe v Wade
which is the reason why abortion is now
illegal in many U.S states a sweeping
reinterpretation of the Second Amendment
are firearms Amendment and now judges
are striking down gun laws left and
right a wholesale attack on voting
rights particularly on the Voting Rights
Act which is the law that prevents race
discrimination at the lower court level
we just had three Trump judges declare
the entire Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau unconstitutional if Republicans
take the Senate then they can block the
confirmation of any judge if you hold
those seats open they're still vacant
when a republican comes to office and
then the Republican can fill them the
Republican party which is an institution
that wants power has figured out that if
it controls the Judiciary it can gain
potentially a permanent veto power over
any law that's enacted over any
regulatory policy that's enacted
regardless of who controls the White
House and regardless of who controls the
Congress they're going after voting
rights hard and if you don't have the
right to vote then you don't have any
rights eventually the voters who have
been disenfranchised don't have any
recourse because they have no way to
change who controls the government and
the government is controlled by people
who don't share their interests that's
the worst case scenario right now we're
still at the point where you know
elections are the best method that can
be used in order to reverse you know
America's Democratic decline
out of the 475 individual House and
Senate elections that will decide
control of Congress most of them are not
close races
the election will really be decided by
these races only about one out of seven
house elections and just a handful of
Senate races and so if you live in one
of those places it means you have a lot
of power over which one of these we
choose
thank you
[Music]